[Music]
hello everyone
uh so in the previous part of the
lecture we had started
our discussion of 2d elasticity and near
the end of the lecture we had
gone on to discuss how important
when proceeding along the root of the
eddy stress function approach
it is to consider the compatibility
equations
so we'll continue from that point
and accordingly our first job
in today's lecture will be to uh to
consider the
compatibility equations and see what
simplifications are possible
and what we can do when proceeding on
the root of this edit stress function
approach
the first of the compatibility equations
let me use the white color so the first
of the compatibility equations involves
the epsilon xx epsilon yy and epsilon xy
we're going to write that down
so as written you can see that uh
other than the fact that each of these
strain components epsilon x x epsilon y
y and epsilon x y
particularly within the consideration of
plane stress
has no dependence on z other than that
there is no simplification here so as
written it remains
okay but uh considerable
uh simplifications will be possible in
the subsequent
compatibility equations as you will soon
see so the next one
is l square epsilon yy
del y square plus del square epsilon
z ah sorry i made it
let's take here this should be z square
del square epsilon uh yy
del z square plus del square epsilon z
del y square is equal to twice del
square epsilon
y z
del y del z now
we had already seen in the previous
lecture
that epsilon yz
is equal to zero we have also seen
that epsilon yy because it is a function
of sigma xx and sigma yy
which in turn are functions
only of x and y the
z dependence of epsilon y y is
zero okay so it is not there therefore
when we differentiate
epsilon y y with respect to z it gives
us
zero so this term vanishes system is
also vanishing
so this is just giving us that
del square epsilon zz del y square
is equal to zero the next compatibility
equation
is l square epsilon
z z del x square
plus del square epsilon x x
del z square is equal to
twice l square epsilon zx
del z del x again we have already seen
that epsilon zx is zero
we also know that epsilon x x just like
in the previous
uh case of epsilon yy which is a pure
function of x and y
this epsilon x x is also a pure function
of x and y
it has no z dependence therefore this
term vanishes so overall what we have
here
is that del square epsilon z
del x square is equal to zero
next we have
del square
epsilon x x
del y del z is
equal to so
here we have del del x
minus so i like to write it in this
fashion
minus del del x plus
del del y plus del del z and then fill
up the strain components
so it's just my way of my preferred way
of writing these things because it helps
me to remember
you follow your own method
okay so from this equation uh we note
that just like before when we said that
epsilon x
x and epsilon y y very independent of z
in a similar fashion epsilon x y here is
also independent of z
so this term vanishes epsilon zx
by itself is zero epsilon y z by itself
is zero
and finally the epsilon x x may have
a dependence on y so this derivative
with respect
to y is fine but it also has a
derivative with respect to z
and we have already seen that epsilon x
x is only a function of x and y
so this term also vanishes so overall
what we have from here
is a zero equal to zero form so that is
identically satisfied
next uh the next compatibility equation
is in terms of the epsilon yy
so this is del z del x
is equal to again just like before we
always similar strategy for writing this
out
so this here is y z this is
zx and this is x y
and again this term vanishes because
epsilon xy is not a function of z
epsilon zx by itself is zero epsilon y z
by itself is zero
and this epsilon y y is not a function
of z so this term vanishes
so again we have a zero equal to zero
form
and finally we have l square epsilon z
del x del y is equal to
delta z again like before we write it
out
current y z epsilon zx
and epsilon x y here again epsilon x y
not a function of z
epsilon zx by itself is 0 epsilon yz by
itself is 0.
epsilon zz mind you is not 0.
and we have already said that epsilon zz
is a function of x and y so this term on
the left hand side
is not zero so all that we can say here
is that this equation simplifies
to del square epsilon says that del x
del y is equal to zero so you see
the only equations that are remaining
really are this first equation
this one this one involving the epsilon
zz
and this final one involving the epsilon
z
the remaining two equations are just
zero by zero form these are trivial
all right now what we are going to do
is to consider only the first of these
equations
okay so in this fashion because we are
not
accounting for what is happening with
the epsilon z
we are just letting it be up and
as we move forward you will see that the
information that is embedded
in this equation only that is utilized
therefore what we are doing as far as
our mathematical formulation is
concerned
this is only an approximate theory okay
so
layer by layer you will you are seeing
that uh
what kind of approximations are embedded
within this general theory and despite
all of this let me just tell you that
the plain stress theory is very much
successful in capturing
a lot of real physical situations
okay so there is a real
strength to these approximations all
right
so uh without any further ado
let us actually go on and utilize the
first of these
uh strain compatibility equations
so this is where we are going to really
start our
uh our formulation our steps with
okay now this
this one is from the compatibility
equation what we are going to do now
is to uh to include here
so the idea is that everything must be
included okay
we need to include everything that we
know so within this we are first going
to include
the information from the constitutive
law
so let's take a look here so
back on this page 2 we had obtained the
simplified versions of epsilon x x and
epsilon yy
simplified under the consideration of
plane stress where the
where the the terms involving the sigma
z they vanished
so uh let's substitute these things
uh as well as this expression of epsilon
x y in terms of sigma x y
okay so we are going to substitute uh
and actually let us
number these equations it will be easier
to keep track of these things
okay so this one is one this is two
this is uh this is three
this is four and
uh let's not call this five and six okay
so you understand that epsilon y is it
is zero and epsilon zx is zero
now um
let us come to uh
let us come to this equation and call
this rather this as
uh equation number so
i stopped here at four so this is 5
let's call this 5
okay so what we are going to do is to
substitute in equation number 5
the information that is present
in equation numbers 1 2
so equation numbers one two and four
okay so
uh
using one
two and four
in five that's what you're going to do
so this is l squared del y
square this epsilon x x is 1 by e
sigma x x minus nu sigma yy
that 1 by e is a constant okay
so we might as well take this out of the
second derivative
and what we'll have inside is this sigma
xx
minus sigma yy
next similarly we'll have the 1 by e
coming out of the second order
derivative
is del square del x square
and inside for the epsilon y y v
uh we have this sigma sorry about that
sigma y y minus nu
sigma xx
and finally for this one we have
2 into 1 plus nu by e
so this part is coming from the 1 by
twice g
this is l square del x del y
sigma x y all right
now you see from all of these terms we
have the 1 by e
canceling out okay
so what we are going to do next is
to collect the uh
the terms involving the sigma
xx so we have a sigma x x here
and we have a sigma x x here but please
note that this is a derivative with
respect to
x square and this is the derivative with
respect to y square
okay so uh
what we have here is something like this
minus nu del square
del x square plus
del square del y square
that operating on sigma xx
in a similar fashion uh
what we have next is for the sigma yy
which is present here and present here
we have
del square del x square
minus nu del square
del y square
operating on sigma yy and the right hand
term
that just remains as it is except that
the one plus
one by e term that gets cancelled out
okay now what we are going to do
is on the left hand side for this term
we are going to add a del square
del x square and we are going to
uh subtract that out also
okay so we are going to add a del square
del x square and we are
going to subtract out a del square del x
square so that
effectively this remains as it is so if
we do that
then what we are going to end up with is
minus 1 plus nu
del square del x square
plus del square del
y square
um
sorry about that a slight mistake here
so this is a sigma xx
so that i obtained from the minus of del
square
sigma x6 del x square which was present
here and
from the plus which i have
included i will get that as
l square del x square
plus del square del y square
this entire thing operating on sigma x6
so you please note that from this term
uh i'm getting this term just by
kind of artificially introducing the del
square sigma xx
del x square term okay
next i'll do a similar sort of thing
here also
uh but i'll do this involving the del
square del y square so i will add
a del square del y square here and
subtract the del square del y square so
effectively it remains the same
just the form becomes somewhat more
symmetrical
okay so
so those of you who can see a bit ahead
will perhaps appreciate the fact that
at least one part of the motivation of
proceeding like this
is to introduce the laplacian operator
here so we have the laplacian operator
being introduced here the laplacian
operating been
being introduced here
right and the right hand side just
remains as it is
next what we'll do is
write this in a slightly uh
slightly cleaner fashion like this we'll
take this one plus new common with this
one plus nu
so
remains inside is this del square sigma
xx del x
square plus l square
sigma yy del y square
okay so please note that there is no
laplacian going on here
okay so this is just as it is
uh this however is a laplacian and this
is a laplacian
okay so what we can do is we can write
them together
as the laplacian operating on sigma x6
plus sigma yy so that
is considerably shortened okay
so the left hand side term is done
on the right hand side this remains
let's call this equation number
six now uh just looking at
equation number six it looks somewhat
symmetrical
but what we do with it okay it's good
that we have utilized our compatibility
equations and within it we have embedded
the information
from the constitutive laws but what
after this
okay so the next plan is to incorporate
within it the information
from the stress equilibrium equations
okay
so please note that earlier when we said
that when we started all this discussion
uh uh within the root of eddy stress
function our motivated
our motivating equations for the stress
equilibrium equations
but once we have started this
formulation we have not actually
utilized
the stress equilibrium equation still
now okay so it's
a time that we uh we do that and you'll
see in a moment
that uh now utilizing the stress
equilibrium equations will actually help
us
in in putting this equation number six
in a slightly more
uh in a considerably more convenient
form okay so let's
do that so let's go to the next page and
consider the stress equilibrium
equations
and this time as i had uh promised
earlier
we are going to include the body force
terms okay
so even though our motivation was set up
by not considering the body force term
because we just wanted to have a simple
version to talk about
uh now we are going to utilize this body
for stem
please note that i am no longer writing
this as rho bx
unlike the stress chapter i'm just
writing this as fx
okay i hope you won't mind
so the next one is l sigma xy
del x plus on del sigma yy
del y plus fy
all right so what we do here is a little
trick
motivated by what we have in equation
number six
you see in equation number six we have
these terms involving the
second derivative of sigma x x with
respect to
x okay so motivated by
that what we'll do is we'll
differentiate the first of these
equations
with respect to x so that will give us a
del square sigma xx
del x square very nicely so perhaps we
can utilize this in equation number six
and is we'll see we will
this is del x del y plus
uh or we can write this on the right
hand side uh
minus del fx del x
okay so let's call this equation number
seven
similarly we'll differentiate the second
of the stress equilibrium equations with
respect to y
motivated by the desire of introducing a
del square del y square
for the sigma yy term uh
if we do that
you're obtaining this equation
and on the right hand side i have the
del fy
del y let's call this equation number
eight
now as you can almost guess
uh even before i write anything more i'm
going to add up this
equation number seven eight okay so if i
do that
what i obtain is del square
sigma xx del x square
plus del square
sigma yy del y squared
so you see these two terms are very much
present
in equation number six
and what i have here is this
plus
twice del sigma x y
del x del y where of course i have
utilized
uh the equality of these two terms
okay so i'm saying that the this
the second order partial derivatives are
continuous which is why the order of the
derivatives do not matter
okay so
this is l f
x del x minus l f
y del y all right
now uh and let's call this equation
number
nine now if we utilize this equation
number nine
back in equation six okay so use
9 in 6
so what do we obtain so
you see these two terms uh
we are going to replace these two terms
by whatever is left
here so we have
a minus 1 plus nu
so this one and then whatever is inside
this bracket
that is basically this thing
minus twice l
square sigma x y del x
del y
minus del
fx del x
minus del fy del y
and what remains in equation number six
is this one
so the laplacian of sigma x6
plus sigma yy
and on the right hand side of equation 6
i have this term
twice 1 plus nu del square
sigma x y del x
del y now very nicely you see if you
just consider this
this first term on the left hand side
this minus and minus is a plus this is 2
into 1 plus nu
del square sigma x y del x del y on the
right hand side also i have the exact
same term
with this first term on the left hand
side it cancels with the
first term on the right hand side
okay so if i just simplify this
algebraically
what i will obtain is l square sigma
xx sigma yy so the laplacian operating
on that
that's equal to i transpose these two
terms to the right hand side
taking care to carry along the one plus
nu
this is going to be minus because this
minus and this minus was already a plus
on the left hand side
so on the right hand side this becomes a
minus
and then i have the del x del x
plus l f y del y
okay so uh let's call this
equation number okay
so now we have this equation
within which the information from the
compatibility equation is embedded
the information from the uh from the
constitutive law is embedded
and the information from the stress
equilibrium equations are embedded
and mind you that all of this has been
done starting out
with the motivation of using the area
stress functions
but till now very surprisingly we have
not yet introduced this
error stress function okay so it is high
time that we
did that now if we just go back
to that motivating page of considering
the area stress function
this page number three we have written
down these these three expressions
all right and these were written down by
keeping in mind
these simplified versions of the stress
equilibrium equations
where for the purpose of illustration
and clarity of
the first discussion the first the
preliminary discussions
we had neglected the body force terms
but now we are considering the body for
systems right
so uh so how so how does it work
okay so it works through a little bit
of a a special consideration and that
consideration
is that uh these for the airy stress
function to work
we say that these body forces this body
force components
fx and fy they must be
derivable from a potential function so
that
seems like a like a rather complicated
thing to say
what we basically mean physically is
that the body force must be conservative
in nature okay so that's what we are
going to discuss next
so
we considered
body forces that are conservative in
nature
and as i said this basically means that
we are going to
be able to write the fx as
the gradient of some scalar potential
v so this v is some scalar potential
similarly the f y is the gradient of
some
scalar potential so basically what we
are saying here is that
the force vector or the body force
vector f
uh that is equal to minus
grad of the scalar potential
okay i'm sure from your studies of
physics
this will ring up there okay so
basically what we are saying here is
that the area stress function approach
is going to work
uh of course very easily if the body
forces are zero
and even if the body forces are not zero
as long as they are conservative in
nature in which case this fx and fy can
be represented in these
terms in terms of the scalar potential
uh it will still work okay so let's see
what what form uh the the stress
uh terms are going to be if this is the
case with the
body force terms so for that we are
again going to take a look at the stress
equilibrium equations but this time
considering the the body force terms so
basically we're just rewriting these
things
okay so what we what we've got uh from
from this one
okay so we are not going to consider
seven and eight rather we are going back
to the source
if we are just going to rewrite that
of course this time this fx we are going
to replace by this
this one
and the y component of the stress
equilibrium equations
which involves the fy
sorry this is del p del y
all right so overall what we basically
have from here
is that we have a term involving the del
del x
that is sigma x x minus v
plus del sigma x y del y
is equal to zero so that's a more
convenient way of writing it
and here it's del sigma xy del x
plus the del del y
terms get clubbed together so it's sigma
yy
minus v okay now
if you just compare with what we had
obtained earlier
okay so see here when we had the only
the sigma xx sitting in the sigma y we
are sitting
without the v terms in the very next
page we were able
to write this down okay so then now the
only difference is that
here we have a del del x term along with
a minus v and here we have a del del y
term along with a minus v that's the
only difference
if that is so then can we not write this
thing again just by saying
that instead of the sigma xx we have a
sigma xx minus v
and the sigma yy minus v that's the only
difference
and we can still use the same forms that
uh professor arie had
first uh written down back in the 19th
century
all right so uh
so from here what we are going to say is
that
sigma x x minus v
let that be del square by del y square
uh the sigma yy minus v
let that be del square by del x square
and the sigma xy well that remains
unchanged as before it's del square phi
del x del y so if we substitute these
particular mathematical forms
back here we'll see that both these
equations are identically satisfied
and let's actually name those equations
number those equations so this was the
last equation number 10
we're going to say that this is equation
number 11
and this is equation number 12 okay
so what we are going to do is
uh we have defined these these forms
so
we go back to this equation number 10
and substitute those forms in terms of
the
area stress function phi that's all that
we are going
that we have to do so we rewrite this
equation number 10
okay so just this equation number 10 we
just rewrite it
so this is a del square sigma xx
plus sigma yy take a look again
minus this entire term and please note
here
that this fx is now minus del v del x
so overall this is going to be a minus
del square v
del x square this f y is minus del v del
y
so it's going to be minus del square v
del y square
okay so uh
that's the only difference there is and
we also note that the minus
and the minus that we had here and the
minus that we had here that just went
outside
and cancelled this minus that was
present okay so when you substitute f x
equal to minus del v del x
and f y equal to minus del v del y that
minus just cancels out with this
okay so overall we have this kind of a
nice form
and when we substitute the sigma x6 are
these terms here
let's see what what it gives us okay so
let's do that on the next page
let's not clutter this page anymore
so l squared
so sigma xx is v plus del square phi
del y square v plus
del square phi del y square
similarly the sigma yy is t
plus del square pi del x square
this term is over and on the right hand
side i have this term
which is basically one plus nu just look
at it carefully this is just the
laplacian of v
okay so we'll write that
so this is basically giving me
twice laplacian of v because this is
twice v
the two goes outside this laplacian acts
on the v
and this term this term and this term
they are together making up a laplacian
we have the laplacian outside and i have
another laplacian inside
acting on the pipe
so overall what i'm going to get is
a del 4 phi so this is the laplacian of
the laplacian
so it's like the by laplacian sometimes
referred to as the
or very commonly referred to as the by
harmonic operator
and on the right hand side i'm going to
get
this is going to be nu minus 1 so
i just write it like this
all right so please note that
this this is this teleport
phi and this del 4 it is the by harmonic
operator
so the laplacian acting on itself is
sometimes
referred to as the by laplacian this is
more common
okay
so overall this equation okay
so uh in the special case that
the body forces vanish or the del square
v is equal to zero
so if
body forces vanish
okay or del square v
is equal to 0 then
del 4 phi is equal to 0
and please note that this is
what is referred to as the by harmonic
equation
okay one of the most important equations
in linear elasticity
and its solutions will be referred to as
the by harmonic solutions
so you see overall what we have managed
to do
is uh
we have we have uh suits
uh i mean it it may look uh rather as
steps of a series of algebraic
manipulations
but through those manipulations what we
have managed to do
is to encapsulate within
just this one very elegant looking
equation this by harmonic equation
the information which is conveyed by
first of all the compatibility equations
uh
the the constitutive law
the stress equilibrium equations okay so
everything
is included in this thing okay so uh
so the idea is that if we solve this
equation uh
for particular physical situations
provide the boundary conditions and
everything
so we should be able to get very uh very
nice solutions to real physical
problems so with this we are going to
end this part of the lecture
and we are going to continue uh our
discussions of the area stress functions
in fact a large part of the remaining
part of this course will be associated
with
solutions of this bi-harmonic equation
all right thank you very much